[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up everybody again another
episode of project stash
today we are at the original i won't say
original for the second location
35 broad street the secret stash jay and
simon bob
today we are taking down the blunt
mobile it's a big project i got some of
my boys here i got my nephew
brian i got mike zapsic i'm even
bringing along
cousin johnny you all know cousin johnny
from kevin's movies
so we're going to be taking down the
blue mobile today and bringing it over
to 65 and setting it up
so the blunt mobile is not even really
fastened
to the structure the weight of it is
sitting inside brackets
so because all the weights shifting
forward so there's
blocks and brackets on the inside of the
mount
to keep it from moving i mean it can't
go nowhere unless somebody decides to
you know take it down well like if the
incredible hulk comes here and like
lifts up the top of it
it could they could pull it right up ah
there's no way
there's nowhere to go but uh he's got
wheels and
um because it was a golf car right yeah
pipes and flames
and all that was another product on the
set we didn't get that we just got the
actual mold
ernie i keep spotting you talking to
that thing and i have some concerns are
you okay
i'm about to grab kevin by his crotch
lifting out of the
blunt movie oh so i'm trying to tell him
not to take it personal
oh man
i was a prostate
someone would try they would steal jay's
tongue someone's
yeah when it was down on the floor and
we just had the ropes around it
people someone grabbed jay's tongue
[Music]
who knows yeah come on everybody get to
work
this little bastard
holy [ __ ] is that
you gonna sit in it you get like 5 000
people in here
a year there's some dead people uh skin
up here
oh
who've been dead for like 15 years right
there
[Music]
oh look at that
[Music]
it's all right so today it's been a
pretty big day we already got the blunt
mobile down off the uh
the platform in the back that was a
chore but we also took down mr brody
today as you can see and let me slide
you down here and show you what else we
got
we took down mr mube he's going back up
in the new stash in his own location
and then of course mr creepy himself
the tusk the tusk is coming over to the
new stash
uh in the front window let's take photos
with somebody could check it out
but the real cool thing the big dog the
original the og
which are going to be taken down next i
think hopefully
check it out chris is the quick stop
sign that
is the original sign from the store
over at 64 leonardo avenue uh actually i
think it's 50
58 52 but that's the original sign that
we used in the movies
all right so some things have to stay a
secret we miraculously got the old sign
down
as you can see the lens is down on the
ground
it's a little it's a little fragile so
we got to be careful
now we're going to take down the box
that i put up my god it's got to be
20 something years ago when kev
originally did the store
but uh this is coming down next going in
the truck and heading over to the new
stash
all right so as you can see we got the
the blunt mobile and its new home and
the new deck here in the new stash
so it was a task took a bunch of us to
get it up here
this thing weighs a ton but uh my buddy
wayne
my nephew brian justin mike zapsic
johnny william
brought her down the street put her back
up here in her new home she looks great
got the jazzer up a little bit more add
a few more details and she'll be good to
go
you know come check her out the new
stash see you next time on project stash
[Music]
you